[Musique]
voilà donc les décrocheurs qui avait été
relaxé dans un premier temps georges
kuzmanovic et ils ont perdu en appel ils
ont 2 250 euros d'amendé ce que c'est
sous l'impulsion d'elisabeth borne est
ce que ça a pu faire pencher la décision
en appel parce que c'était une première
de donner raison à des décrocheurs de
portraits au sein de deux mairies
notamment
je ne sais pas si c'est plus que les
propos d'elisabeth bornes qui ont
influencé les juges
par contre vous donnerai la réponse mais
par contre ce qui est terrible c'est que
toute l'année dernière il ya eu quand
même douze mille arrestations dans le
pays
3000 condamnation gilet jaune un millier
qui ont terminé en prison et un certain
laxisme quant aux policiers qui ont fait
des centaines de blessés graves certains
policiers mais qui ne l'ont pas fait par
volonté personnelle à part quelques-uns
mais qu'ils ont fait sur ordre
puis jeudi comme un soudanais attendent
jeudi spécifiquement que monsieur casta
vert si vous voulez je peux le dire
comme ça est un lâche qui fait faire son
travail de répression auprès du peuple
de france à part des policiers qu'il met
en danger parce qu'il a pris des
policiers administratif des policiers de
la bac qui n'ont aucun entraînement
comme les crs et les gendarmes mobiles
et qui les a mis dans des situations
extrêmement dangereuses alors à lancer
léger léger regret les ont mises en
décibels que georges le peuple de france
j'ai fait toutes les manifestations je
sais très bien ce qui s'est passé ici du
peuple de dieu est ce parce que moi j'ai
porté le département de bignona loiselet
d'inviter au maximum de gilet jaune
c'était 100 mg sur un million et demi
d'habitants
voir la passion pour donner une première
manifestation où les policiers vous dire
où la police voit l'arrivée laissant
l'impression qu'il y à des sanctions
plus fortes du côté des gilet jaune est
moins lourde du côté des polices examen
coffre et puis ne pas être poursuivi
pour tout un tas de la fraction
extrêmement grave
mais il est pourri et vit on attend on a
des gilets jaunes qui n'ont jamais été
ni notre qu'une organisation d'extrême
droite ou d'extrême gauche qui finissent
très très vite en prison n'ont jamais
aucun passé politique
ça s'appelle une incitation enfin c'est
faire en sorte que les gens parlent
viennent pas manifester
[Musique]